venezuela recibe este sábado un
cargamento proveniente de rusia con el
primer lote de 100 mil vacunas es fuck
mix 5 contra el coronavirus la
vicepresidenta del psir rodríguez
participó en el acto de recibimiento al
cual acudió también el embajador de
rusia en cumplimiento del acuerdo
suscrito entre ambas naciones la llegada
de estas dosis permitirá el inicio del
proceso de inmunización en la población
dando prioridad al personal médico que
se encuentra en primera línea para
atender a los pacientes contagiados con
el virus luego el sector a vacunarse
serán los educadores venezuela ha
pactado con rusia la adquisición de 10
millones de vacunas en un año el primer
lote que llegó representa el 1% total
del pactado en noviembre por una
delegación del gobierno venezolano en
una visita a moscú el pasado 13 de enero
el ministerio de salud de venezuela
informó sobre el registro de la vacuna
para su uso de emergencia en el
territorio venezolano antes de ello
venezuela participó de la fase 3 de los
ensayos clínicos del fármaco ruso con 2
voluntarios para esta etapa recibir un
cargamento el pasado 2 de octubre de